los planes de china para controlar la
pandemia en hong kong encontraron
resistencia en un sindicato de
trabajadores de la salud pro demócratas
la alianza de empleados de la autoridad
hospitalaria hong kong está formada
durante las protestas contra beijing el
año pasado pidió sabotear el plan
universal de pruebas que adelantará el
gobierno chino desde el primero de
septiembre un proyecto que realiza en
cooperación con un equipo de 60
profesionales de la salud de china
continental para tratar de controlar la
pandemia hong kong el gobierno local
tiene un solo objetivo usar el control
del virus para hacer todo para complacer
al gobierno central de china incluso si
eso significa poner la política por
encima de todas las cosas el sindicato
integrado por unas 20.000 personas dijo
que en las pruebas universales no son
una manera eficiente de invertir los
recursos ni de controlar el virus por lo
que se deben implementar pruebas
localizadas el activista pro demócrata
joshua wong acompañó este llamado y
reiteró que sólo existe una salida para
detener la propagación del virus es hora
de darse cuenta cómo los gobiernos de
beijing y hong kong
fingen y facilitan la interferencia en
holcomb con la excusa del coi 19 cerrar
la frontera es la única salida la
desconfianza incrementan hong kong luego
de que el gobierno chino estableció una
nueva ley de seguridad nacional en junio
para restringir la libertad de expresión
a los ojos de los críticos pero terminó
de consolidarse luego de que beijing que
pospusiera un año más las elecciones
legislativas de septiembre citando
riesgos para la salud pública por la
pandemia